this chapter which i call
we got the band back together we're
putting the band back together
forget it don't wait they get the band
back together
you know ishan wong is like completely
played out that's why ellen powell
became
ceo at that time because he said man
this has just burnt me out this has been
really tough to get it back here
but hats off and a lot of credit got to
the series b where now they had the gas
in the tank to go forward
as a standalone company and do the kind
of things they want to do they bring the
leadership back
slow who was one of the early employees
i think he was employee number one right
paul wasn't he employee number one
number one
number one and he comes back as cto 2017
along with the series c which is now a
1.8 billion dollar valuation
and now reddit after all these years is
in the unicorn club
and they're off and running and there's
only one thing you can say about a
company
that took 12 years to cross a billion
dollars in valuation finally get there
is damn they finally did it
and they're all really running 2019
300 million dollars sequoia's in there
10 cents in there we know who 10 10 is
and boom comes 2021 where everyone
suddenly knows exactly who reddit is the
ones that weren't paying attention
as wall street bets the entire robin
hood saga happens
and by the way right after that they
raised 250
million dollar round so that their total
financing to date is 800 million dollars
over 16 years and they are now the
number 18
website by traffic in the world number
seven in the united states
46 of their traffic coming from the
united states it's over 50 if you
include the uk and canada
and now guess what this little comment
that was made
by paul graham in many ways reddit
is the front page of the internet when
you think about the subreddits
and all of the administration over
topics
if you remember back to any of the early
days where you have topical forms and
everybody everybody can join in
well basically the ask me anything
really kind of achieves scale
thanks to reddit as a matter of fact
they almost
broke the internet in 2012 when
candidate obama
president obama now a candidate to be
re-elected in 2012
he didn't ask me anything on reddit and
they did
almost break the internet because
despite all the infrastructure and
everything that reddit had
to handle scale there was so much
traffic on that day
for that they almost broke the internet
and so
very famous for the amas and the things
that go with it
also they're also famous for you know
trying editorially
to make decisions about things and there
were some
right wing sites and some uh you know
people that were way out their sites
maybe right and left they were you know
famous for one part of it
people would say censorship but i really
think they were trying to moderate and
curate what was going on here
at the same time that twitter and
facebook were getting
getting in the chops from the government
many other people about what they were
or weren't doing
reddit was there too getting some
criticism but we were really
i think through the administration and
the moderation i think reddit was doing
a better job and that's my opinion
and they come up to wall street bets we
all know what that was where all the
wall street bets people come together
which showed you the power
of the front page of the internet and
the power
of what was going on here in terms of
those subreddit forums
they weren't just maybe a fleeting come
and go tweet because that tweet
disappears and goes on down
as other tweets come in i've always
found reddit to be
more sustained in its impact on me
specifically in formula one forums or
news that i care about
and there's more that the biz doc cares
about than formula one forums i watch
wall street bets
and it really feels to me that there's a
more curated sustained presentation
of the information and news coming
through reddit than the fleeting nature
of of twitter although twitter is a
great place for breaking news and you
can follow
certain reporters there like stock
reporters and things which may
of interest to you that you want to
follow them as well but i really think
that the
crowd source structure that is reddit is
really you know i think better
than any other place to go get you know
curated news
especially since you've got moderation
individual tweets aren't moderated
you can have one crazy person that has
2500 people just hit them
as a like and you know there's not much
there there's a more thoughtful dialogue
and discourse
with moderation happening on reddit
thanks for watching the short clip if
you like that i'd like to see the whole
episode
you can find it right here and for even
more
subscribe to this channel right here